Well, sadly, as we learn more about the lead
up to this horrible mass shooting.
Another one?
Yeah.
Not the one in Texas.
Not the one.
We're now up to the one in Highland Park,
Illinois.
As we learn more about it and we learn more
about the shooter.
We learn that yet another one of these often
repeated phrases from the more guns in more
places, American right wing is meaningless.
It is worth absolutely nothing to us.
We have now learned that the shooter legally
bought the guns used in the mass shooting
after becoming known to police and police
taking a number of knives from the eventual
shooter.
The right loves to say, listen, we can't take
rights away.
But if there are specific people known to
police believed to be dangerous, we need some
kind of system to prevent them from getting
guns.
But we can't
take away too many rights either.
And really, we don't we shouldn't do anything
about guns in general.
Well, we had that here and yet still able
to legally buy firearms.
Let's get into The New York Times article
that explains this Highland Park suspect was
known to police, bought guns legally.
The man accused of killing seven and wounding
dozens of others in a shooting that terrorized
a 4th of July parade had been investigated
by the local police before.
Officers had responded in 2019 after someone
reported that he had tried to kill himself
and they came to his home a few months later,
seizing a knife collection after a family
member reported he had pledged to, quote,
kill everyone.
They knew about him.
Still in the years since the man was able
to legally by several guns in Illinois, including
a high powered rifle that officials said
was used in the attack on Monday.
Tuesday, he was charged with seven counts
of first degree murder.
The details of the prior police visits raised
questions about whether the Illinois authorities
missed opportunities to use their relatively
strict firearms laws to block his gun purchases
and about whether a newly, newly signed federal
gun law might have made a difference had it
been in force earlier.
In a statement, the Illinois State Police
defended the decision to grant him a permit
to own a gun, which he applied for in December
2019.
The police said he appeared to have prepared
for weeks to attack the parade on Monday morning,
had used a fire escape to climb atop a downtown
business to fire dozens of rounds from a high
powered rifle into the crowd.
He escaped by discarding his rifle, blending
into the crowd, wearing women's clothing.
Eventually they got
him, as we all know.
So, you know, again, we can go back and forth.
This is just it's a circular firing squad
and it's almost, you know, weird to use the
term firing squad proverbially when we're
talking about a literal mass shooting here.
But we engage in the same pointless circles
here in the United States with this stuff.
Well, people need their rights, but in some
cases we might be okay, slightly restricting,
if only on a temporary basis after some kind
of investigation, even though it's kind of
denying people due process to limit people's
ability to legally get firearms.
But do we actually enforce those laws?
Well, not really.
And then Joe Biden wants to do something and
so do Democrats.
And Republicans don't want to take away rights,
but they're willing to do it.
But the bill barely does anything anyway.
But had it
been enforced, maybe it would have prevent.
We need a systemic.
We need a rewrite.
This would be like if you have a script for
a film and one person says they want to tweak
a little bit of the dialog and eventually
you come to realize we've got to throw it
out and rebuild this thing from the ground
up.
When other countries look at the United States
and I know the right wingers don't care the
right wingers now, the thing they love saying
is we fought a war to separate from Europe,
from England.
Why would we care what other countries think
about us now?
Why do we care what that what England thinks
about what's going on here?
Doesn't matter where we fight to get away
from them.
Go.
The world looks at what's happening and they
see these piecemeal fringe discussions.
And by fringe, I
mean just dealing with the fringes, the edges
of the debate.
Well, maybe if you call and you say, I think
they're dangerous guys.
If you're under 25, should you even be able
to buy any kind of rifles?
I mean, that's one of my one of the points
on my 10 to 12 point proposal.
If you're under 25 to get any firearms, shouldn't
you need community letters of support from
adults who say, I have no concerns with this
person having a firearm?
So, again, I know that people love to say,
well, this one provision wouldn't have done
anything in this particular case.
Right.
But if you look at my list, which is I didn't
come up with the points, these are points
that have been floating around of 10 to 12
ideas to limit mass shootings, to prevent
mass shootings for five or even six of
them could have directly impacted this particular
shooter, having had the knives seized because
people were worried he would kill everyone,
should have disqualified him from legally
buying firearms.
Oh, but, sir, that's not due process, guys.
Look at the situation we have in this country
under 25, straight up.
Shouldn't even be able to get some of these
types of weapons.
Would have had it.
So I could go on.
These things can make a difference.
We haven't even tried them.
We tried the assault weapons ban in the nineties
and it did reduce the number of frequency
and severity of mass shootings to some degree.
Now, some will say, well, was it statistically
significant?
Okay, that's one of ten or 12 provisions that
I've put together.
We have supposedly I mean, listen, do we really
believe doors are going to solve the problem
of outdoor parade mass shootings?
Do we really believe securing fire escapes
is going to solve the issue of shootings in
a movie theater?
We need systemic change.
Very few of those in positions of power are
willing to really do it.
Talking about Republicans here and you know,
we can keep talking about doors and ceilings
and walls and windows all we want.
It's not going to make a difference.
Big picture.
So that's where we are.
Police knew about him.
They seized his knives.
They were worried he was a danger to himself
and others.
And then he went and legally bought guns and
did what he did on Monday.
That's where we are